will take five suggestions we'll divide
you guys up so everyone's got a fair go
and we'll drop B do a freestyle rap
we'll get suggestion number one come to
this side first what would you like to
hear a freestyle rap about
okay so there were there were two gummy
bears and Pediatric Dentistry which are
that's perfect that goes together
perfectly that's incredible are you a
pediatric dentist
you've got one more right here okay good
for you and well done and the rest are
you [__] idiots who will never never
own property anywhere they're [__]
raking it in Pediatric Dentistry is a
[__] con they grow naturally unless
you pour sugar in their mouth they're
gonna stay good Pediatric Dentistry
gummy bears are your best friend yeah
you [__] love them PD Advantage gummy
bears middle middle front of the room
what you wanna rap out
climate change that's what hyper
localized climate change at Harvard us
Boston is really struggling with a only
Boston now okay um cool climate change
at Harvard University is that where you
study or
why are you are you with these people
sir I know anymore I've cut her Grant ah
okay climate change climate change at um
Harvard great I mean that was it's weird
that you teach her Harvard when I said
middle front of the room and you were
like well that doesn't apply to me
because I'm I'm at the back of the room
but I will ignore those rules middle
front to the room let's get your
suggestion
stained glass windows and you are of
antipodean stock where abouts are you
from
New Zealand that's what you say antipody
and not Australians if you call a New
Zealander in Australia they won't do
anything they're [__] but if you call
an Australian a New Zealander they'll
[__] hunt you down but New Zealand
has no Coastal defenses and so they're
inherently weak but you
you are the only person here who will
survive the climate change that is
coming for us all you are in the safest
place are you a connoisseur of the
stained glass
you've got them all across the country
look at [__] NASA first world nation
over there they
he's just looking at this like we've got
better than that in New Zealand
that kind of looks like your ex prime
minister doesn't it
[Applause]
I don't know which one I'm referring to
okay um this side of the room what would
you like a rap about
biostatistics [__] hell do you want
to go sit with those Pricks at the back
just
I was a bit worried and I was at Cinco
de Mayo they're going to come up with
they're gonna be like getting your
titties out you're like well no
biostatistics
um obviously I know what biostatistics
means but for the benefit of everyone
else in the room do you wanna
just want to just explain
biostatistics what's what's give us a
pressy
health related research great cool that
doesn't help me at all but um
[Applause]
[Music]
comedy Rhymes the freestyle funny to
share look under a chair I find a tiny
wee gummy bear stuck like the chewing
gum pop it on my tongue wipe it so long
did I think it's so wrong I love the
sucrose the nice little sugar I take the
back of gummy bear stole it from my
brother I go at Halloween and I'm
getting all the candy I say when I'm
hungry package it comes in handy I
stored it under my pillow at night in
case I feel kind of tight in my stomach
or right a little gummy bear yellow red
or maybe green there's not a blue one
that would be obscene the E numbers
inside make the kids go crazy if it
comes to brushing teeth and you kind of
lazy you'll be like oh [__] get the
tooth lost you hate the British why
because we don't know what floss is we
get so confused like nope I'm not using
my teeth or my tongs with the Rope so
tiny but you stretch gymnastic the
Dentistry is specializing PD theatric
the opposite of geriatric that's old
ladies and they ain't had teeth in there
for [__] dailies when it comes to
kids it's much more fun you're like oh
this flavor is bubble gum on the
toothpaste and then you graduate to Mint
if it comes through on the bottom then
you think it's usually the first four on
the bottom of the jaw I met one
pediatric dentist before and they were
as lovely and rich as you but at least
you knew the section that you sat into I
said hey front of the room are you sure
what you want to rap about and you were
like Harvard shouting there from the
back please please please you need to
strip the lady of her PhD researching
some stuff it's ever so strange we can't
understand why the climate change is
well the petrochemicals all the plastic
use all the things dumped into the sea I
must have juice but you're fine you're
just there in your little bubble in your
muted New Zealand if you're in trouble
when the rest of the world is demolished
to Rubble you'll be coming over there
see my guy on the double he'd be like oh
hey you doing here bro we wear sandals
and we've got stained glass windows what
else do we do we made the flat wide and
the lovely Pavlova we're feeling all
right see how the light comes through
the glass you know New Zealand it's
really Top Class it's what you need to
see yes I adore sadly you can't
pronounce things I adore like I slipped
on the floor or I slipped on the floor
different E's and eyes vowels I could
not ignore now the last one I really
wish I'd missed it resist this what the
[__] is biostatistics well we work in
healthcare why is the accent still I'll
switch back to you ladies paying the
bill with all the money they made they
adore it biostatistics basically we can
scam your insurance making sure we push
the prices up buy a statistics just
means you're making cash off of the
drugs
okay